hello and welcome to this video is the
recording if she on I think it is so
this is the chest opening Q&A video
number two so this is the first one um
based on your questions that have been
posted in the first video I actually
disabled further comments in the first
video so I have a yeah I have the
opportunity to look at all of them and
this is the only way you have to do it I
think efficiently if if I keep all those
videos open the old ones then people
keep asking questions in the old videos
then I kind of lose track completely so
I'm going to do it like that I'm going
to close the comments for the first one
and let leave them open for this for the
current one maybe I will go for some
other solution at a later stage
and don't do it with YouTube comments
but for now let's do it like that so if
you have additional questions but post
them right in the comments to this video
okay in the first one I got really tons
of comments roughly 40 or so and I want
to make those videos
you don't want to make them like two
hours long three hours long or something
like that so what I'm going to do is I'm
taking the questions here from the first
video and make a roughly thirty minutes
video of it and if it's thirty minutes
I'm going to call it a day and I'm going
to make look at the other questions at
video number three so it will be
probably like a collection of question
that will mmm it will be answered over
time so I'm not going to make so long
videos that nobody's going to watch them
it's my experience two hours is a bit
much so let's get rollin the first
question from the first video is can you
cover the pause pause mouths gambit
um thankfully
Zuba is telling me what is this I
wouldn't have known that this is called
Portsmouth gambit birth mouse probably
butchering this I'm not sure he wants to
know what this is playable in over the
board chess his opponents are rated
around 1,800 to 2,000 okay first of all
I wasn't aware that this is an opening
but I looked at this briefly and I think
it is probably something that you can do
on that level that you're mentioning it
is obviously a gambit one part of the
question is what white should do after
black plays e5 this is not a move that I
would consider as black at all because
before is a pawn you simply take and
don't play some silly move like e5 and
anyway I think that b5 there should be
better for white something like this
must be a bit better for white probably
with Bishop c4 I analyzed this briefly
not it stopped something that I looked
at like an hour or so but I think it's
fine and I would play b5
even though move like Bishop c4 has
probably played but I think if five is
english-speaking previant move but yeah
the critical line of this opening has to
be Knight takes before I think and after
that white is playing like this so what
what is basically doing is he's playing
a c3 Sicilian um but with the missing be
pawn and an extra tempo yeah best for
black I would assume as d5 here and then
after this yeah White has a choice what
to play their moves like 90 to 93
I checked it briefly white seems to have
a bit of compensation I think this is a
little bit dicey
it wouldn't be my cup of tea to play
something like that but if you don't
mind a bit of risk and I think it's kind
of okay you would probably surprise many
people and
I'm not sure what people would actually
play there if they don't know what to do
people might take this and this mmm this
for example is something that I know
it's kind of interesting
sorry for the voice so I think it's
playable it's too risky for my for my
personal taste but it's um certainly
something that you can do against this
opposition um a question here bright
teal chess is the D pawn systems like
the color are very soft okay for 1400
players yeah of course they are they are
fairly solid and simple to learn given
the choice between the color and other D
pawn systems or the various soft I would
really if you want to do something of B
to share I would really advocate the
London the the very soft is not bad they
are like this is the very soft with the
knight on c3 but oftentimes you want C 4
and later here if you want to play c4
and you can still do that with the
London I think the London is an easier
entry point maybe for later expansion to
more mainline openings for example if
black plays something slowish let's say
yeah I would strongly advocate to play
c4 and place a place C for D for style
opening that you can later use the
experience that you get here with more
typical D pawn opening play can be used
for later well the very soft is such a
such an isolated part and say off for
structures that it's kind of you're
gaining knowledge but of an area that is
probably not super useful in the very
long run with with the London this is a
bit more it's a bit more flexible the
color the sisters with III is of course
playable but I wouldn't really do that
if I have the Bishop f4 option is just
more active so given the choice I would
probably
a piece of paper actually I would
probably rather go for the London um so
there's a question about the Queens
gambit accepted with black I'm still
going to keep it from the white
perspective I'm switching BOTS all the
time it gets tricky so um and him Jacob
is asking his systems with this
efore and 93 is giving him a hard time
okay first of all 93 is not great
because of the move a six is this
something that you should check
why does actually now a little bit
struggling to be still okay let's say
white is still okay but he has to be
very very careful in some cases you have
excellent chance to even keep the pawn
the line that is oftentimes seen in
games is this for example where all of a
sudden this funky night covers the pawn
this position for example is already
better for black
so 93 is viewed as an imprecise move
it's still a move that is played quite
often on the amateur level so it's
something you should be ready for
against eform my recommendation is to
play Knight f6 there are other options
but I think Knight f6 is the most
straightforward mostly because the lines
now are fairly clear Knight c3 is not
good due to five
please check the details I cannot show
everything this is good for black so
they go me 595 Bishop c4 and here you
have a choice between the moves knight
c6 Knight b6 or Bishop f5 the latest
fashion is Bishop a5 a move that I have
played sometimes in my blitz games and I
thing will catch white players unawares
one interesting point is that after
Queen b3 or main point effect is that c6
is playable because queen bee 796 is
actually fine for black I've had this in
my blitz game so we'll check them out
this is a very simple recipe against the
Queens gambit accepted with E 4 and you
have a big advantage there that you can
play on move 5 align that white players
probably never have seen this is a very
nice thing if you can do that so this is
what I would do in the qga absolutely
and then hit a question that don't quite
understand honestly
Mitchell 31 41 he is going back he's
saying his question is about fighting
against the Slav setup with the white
pieces when starting with c4
I like playing aggressive and sounds
chess recently discovered there is the
following gambit line and he's giving
this line c4 c6 93 d5 deform
d take C for uniform b5 what is my
opinion on this line would you recommend
this line for an aggressive player
strive to get an imbalance position as
possible and still sound and yeah thing
is this is a line that black plays right
black is taking on c3 and this is a
sideline black usually does not take on
c3 but they most of the time playing I
have six for Regulus laughs and the
question here is a little bit what
exactly are you aiming for with Knight
c3 but you can do that it's not a bad
move but what is your idea was naturally
DC free is a sideline a DC 4 as a
sideline and after a 4 B 5 you would
probably play a form and want to pawn
back otherwise you're probably in a
shady gambit yeah some something like
that is the Geller gambit which is
generally viewed as unsound for white
it's not unplayable but not something
that is very commonly seen yea wide
usually place like this and then we get
get this as the main line which is play
with white absolutely but the thing is
you are choosing this move here or you
can also do this from water and the
human you need some justification for
that because if you just want to play
this
for example the asset appointed starting
with Nancy 3 instead of 9 f3 so Knight
c3 does not have huge advantages of
doing this um there are differences but
for example here if black plays a six
you have fo are so gentle maybe Knight
c3 is the more aggressive move in some
way but if black plays Knight f6 which
will happen in the absolute majority of
cases you need to ask yourself what you
move us if you play 90 of three you just
have transposition and you can play III
but if you want to play with III you can
argue that may be the other way around
like like this
as more points because in this case in
this case you sometimes have ideas where
you can actually develop the night here
for example with be three but should be
two ninety two and later ninety five so
I'm not totally sure that I understand
the question I mean if the question is
is night see three playable yes you can
play like that um is it a promising
gambit I wouldn't say so I think that in
most cases like with a form the material
quality would be restored quite quickly
if you just don't do anything here and
play something like this I think black
has quite decent chances to be okay with
ninety of six gala gambit or ecigs
transposing to a line of the no t-bone
[Music]
I'm not really a huge believer in just
like playing like this and just develop
pieces I mean yes you have a center but
black has an extra pawn and those pawns
are actually quite annoying so I think
here it will ultimately come probably to
this position you can also go to be one
but ninety two is more common to this
position which is fine for white but
it's it's your call if you want to allow
this most of the time it's not relevant
because black would do something else
Knight f6 in particular like night at
6:00 a.m. the next question about Peter
Gasper is he's got a problem with white
against the Banco gambit and with black
against the Kings gambit so yeah this is
an easy one relatively easy one so with
white you don't like the banker game but
the first option that you can have is
and that depends on your repertoire if
you play 90 of three based quite often
you could of course just do this which
stops the bank oh yeah after c5 d 5b v
you are not as you're not forced to play
c4 which is supposed to the banker but
you can play Bishop g5 which is rather
dangerous for black I mean I've compiled
a bank or gambit repertoire where I have
this with black as my recommendation but
it is
tough to play it's not easy to play and
quite nice actually for white I think as
a practical weapon if you need to play
see form
and get into this position you have the
option to decline it with 93 that's not
not a bad idea
but I would actually recommend to select
a line within the bank oh I don't know
what you have tried of course that would
be helpful to know but if you want an
option that is not so sharp and
relatively easy to maintain I would
recommend to take the pawn and after a
six clay b6 that's a good practical
recommendation like will regain the pawn
most of the time he will take
immediately and then you play a set up
with Knight c3 Knight f3
efore 92 94 is the general plan black
loses a bit of time with the squiggles
and without the a file open black hasn't
does not have such clear counter play I
think black is okay with precise play of
course but this is something that gives
you very good control and it is quite
easy to learn this is much easier to
play for example like a sharp line like
f3 yah I know there are some gambit
style nonsense I'm not very correct I
would recommend this you can also study
to take the pawn but this is much more
work so I think b6 is a good practical
weapon if you want to cut down on
theoretical workload and there's the
question about the King's gambit what to
do with black a line that he mentions is
is this one this is something that I had
recommended in on my youtube channel in
an earlier video some years ago and it's
still a good line he says he still has
some problems there however after I've
looked at this very extensively for my
fighting for Lackawanna repertoire which
is a fully 45 repertoire so I have to
cover the King's gambit
I'm absolutely certain that thinking is
best
and now after Bishop c4 Queen age form
is good for black and after 93 9 f6 is
also good for black so the King's gambit
is just not good for white it's what it
is if white is very precise very very
precise I think it could be equal but
white is struggling to prove that so if
you want a really hard weapon against
the King's gambit play like that you
would be better in almost every game
because it's not even so well known um
yeah like after this you go here and
protect the pawn from the sign and now
attack this on formation it is still
quite murky but objectively speaking
black is fine this is an opening for
example that is for me completely dead
for correspondence chess or computer
chess just white is just not good in
good shape um Peter also has a question
about the Italian game he says he gets
very boring positions of the Italian and
wants something more interesting I do
understand what you say I have the same
issue and this is why I cannot answer
the question like offhand yeah and it's
something that I'm going to keep in mind
and I need to check maybe some ideas to
give give some advice but not like
immediately I don't have a solution
really I mean in the Italian like it
sounded solid but it's not super
exciting um the next question when new
cash is about the Queens gambit accepted
with Knight f3 and he has a very general
question I should analyze typical white
plans after six a six what he means is
the position here
which is the absolute main line of the
qga I mean it's a bit tough to analyze
this and because White has a boatload of
moves really a huge array of moose I can
give you some advice though some general
advice what I would play let's say if
I'm in this position if I want super
solid yeah you can take on c5 which is
probably equal but black still has to
prove it it's still a little bit a
little bit more comfortable for white it
is not very exciting though as you watch
Red Queen's now immediately if you once
solid but with a little bit more bite
yeah I would play b3 this is currently
in fashion the idea is simply to develop
the bishop and in case of C takes take
with the night and get a position this
is of course nonsense sorry Black has to
start with Bishop d7 in order to prepare
that to get a position like that where
White has slightly easy again man the
bishop won't be - is just a good piece
so honestly if I'm in this position
which I'm usually not just for
repertoire reasons I play something else
with white I would play b3 if you play
want to play sharper and you want a
sharper position I would recommend to
play Bishop b3 or Bishop d3 those two
moves
tend to lead to iqp positions that have
bit sharper the reason why you move the
bishop voluntarily is that you want to
answer b5 with a four so if you want to
play sharper I would go for one of the
bishop moves and if you want to play
more solid I want to I would want to
play b3 this is my current take on this
what does not seem to be too promising
is Queenie to the very old main line
it's not a bad move but it doesn't seem
to oppose black many problems also there
is a fourth which also seems to be fine
for black
I think so I hope this has helped a
little bit there is a question here how
to use chess base to search for lines
this is a little bit yeah it doesn't
quite fit into this into this concept
maybe it's something that I keep in mind
maybe for a separate type of video the
next question an opening psychology
question and I think a very important
one and if you play a place into an
opening line which you know extremely
well should you move instantly to show
dominance and at best in Sofia or do you
show or should you act like you know
nothing and whatever you had to put on
some kind of show and I have a very
clear advice there and you don't mention
spending time this is an important thing
because sometimes people ask me if I
actually know everything should i search
spend a bit of time like they're put on
a show that i'm not yeah that are not
knowing stuff and Maxie advises don't do
that just play the move immediately yeah
just play immediately the certain
dominance is helpful to like showing
that you know stuff is generally helpful
and simply yeah convert your knowledge
into advantage on the clock being head
on the clock is super useful in
particular if you are the stronger
player anyway the recipe of having a
good opening position against the
somewhat weaker opponent with more time
on the clock that translates into so
many points you cannot count it however
if you have a decent good position
whatever and you burn time for no reason
it can be it can be a problem I have had
games where ahead like if you play
increment shares way ahead my starting
time on move 20 simply because I knew
what I was doing and then I just play
the moves I mean you don't have to blitz
it but just like play play them quickly
and don't put on any sort of show I
don't think there's much benefit to that
yeah I really don't think so
um but this is maybe
dude kind of thing I really don't don't
care so much about psychological place
or whatever I don't think that it helps
too much having more time on the clock
is very useful um yeah the next one is
not real question it was a comment on
the on the video and that I did the
first one was about about
recommendations what to do against D for
that looks a little bit like the Alec
I'm and that's true there is a mention
here by material Jack that this is Alec
on types to play absolutely you're right
I did not mention that opportunity the
queen's gambit accepted with e4 is a lot
like the Alec on in this variation very
similar in her and and would work
definitely however of course in the qga
there are other lines any force so this
is not a full-scale solution and it's a
bit more difficult to play of British a
little bit of British or elegant like
against other lines there are still
possibilities though the qga is an
opening that I generally think is quite
fine um the next question by a whole and
margul I'm actually managing quite a
knot here I hope I'm not talk talking
too fast but I think it's kind of okay
he says he plays solid but not
completely symmetric on opening with
black like the [ __ ] on against efore and
the qgd against d4 he always has
promised though with playing against 93
or c4
what would you recommend to play and
well if you play the qgd it's not a big
problem man you just play me six and d5
hmm yeah and whatever white does that
it's not deform will be a red tip where
you should look look at some lines and
make a choice
the only problem could be and you're not
you're not mentioning this and that you
might go for the qgd with other move
orders that is possible if you play for
example against d4 if you play something
this and only play the huge Edie here
and let's say here you play something
else
I played the name is oh and then again
see for it's a bit more of a problem but
generally speaking a six is of course
the way to go in many cases you will
transpose for example after night see 3d
5d for you have a qgd and now your
choice if you play the semi Tara
then I assume that you play this not a
big problem the only thing that I can do
is he can just play without d4 so he
could try things like let's say this and
here you need to make a choice you say
you play the bishop before katana okay
that means that this is a bit of an
annoyance because there is no check on
before hmm okay it's not the end of the
world oh I would simply learn something
that is specific to this so for example
interesting lines that you can play here
are taking this is the most solid line
or you can play the sharper line d4
simply playing as if you were white and
gain space like this this this this
which is a benoni
with reversed colors white actually has
to Tempe with it's funny you know it's a
lot because he's white and he's 65 will
be two moves but it's so probably quite
okay for black so it is ambitious but
it's it's playable I would do one of
those one you can of course play we
should be seven castles and so on and
just allow a different line of the
Catalan um if you don't want to do that
I recommend to take or play d4 for for
sharp or play against ninety of three of
course D 5 D for go transpose c4 e6 is
basically what we just looked at and
white of course can play stuff like g3
and he again you need to make a
judgement call
what to do against this you've got quite
a good range of options you can still
play Knight FC
ethics and the wait proceedings or what
I think is quite interesting is to play
very ambitious here with c5 and 96
trying to play e5 many people especially
they are not super strong I don't know
the opening then well well actually a
now e5 which basically gives you the
right pieces in a king's in Ian what
they play the the reverse Grune felt
this is a good opening I think for white
not like white wins or anything but I
think it's an attractive option for
white however if you know your stuff you
can be very okay there as well it's for
is equal maybe if you'd be Prince you
are precise but this is the only let's
say problem variation for black if you
play like this everything else is fine
really sometimes white tries stuff like
this the reverse banco but this is
honestly not very good yeah you take the
pawn and you're happy I mean the tempo
is actually not very relevant so this is
an ambitious option against 93 of course
you can do e 6 and BB solid as well
there's there's quite a good quite good
amount of choice there um the next
question by met Jorge is the following
systems with d5 d6 and a6 viable as a
main repertoire against D pawn openings
are only as an occasional de lions I
don't even know that word I learned a
new world alliance um given that those
lions are nowadays played by people like
cards and karana it is probably fine
yeah we're talking about a 6 here
a six here um it depends probably a
little bit on your level of opposition
if you want to play it every single game
the idea of the move by the way is to
prepare the capture on a good day you
might capture and keep the pawn um I
don't really want to go into this in
much detail because it is a fairly broad
subject yeah white can't play many moves
and there are some ideas there as you
probably gathered have looked at just
four black already it is interesting um
I think you could give a go I could cook
you could give that line ago as a as a
main choice because it's still not in
the focus of any white player who knows
this stuff a six nobody and I don't
think you can refuel it by preparation I
mean that that would have happened then
yeah Carson has played it again and yeah
if Magnus is kind of experimental
sometimes in the opening but it's not
going to play something that doesn't
work okay the next the next question a
simple line against Trump off scheme
that's a Trump yeah what you do there is
there something simple um I'm not
certain sometimes difficult to tell what
people perceive as simple and and not so
simple and the probably easiest move is
d5 let's start with that where you allow
Y to take this cannot be super scary on
a step black has fairly easy development
and no weaknesses the double pawn is not
an issue oftentimes white does not even
take or play something like III after we
see if I have an idea for our options
and d5 is probably the simplest a line
that is a bit more ambitious maybe that
I played them a bit in the past is e six
it is ambitious because now if Y plays
Knight f3 or 92
that is kind of toothless you can play
c5 and be six then the only really
interesting move is Eve or after which
you can play age six and now gain the
bishop pair and yeah if you know me I
always like to have the bishops and and
this is why I was attracted to that line
I have to say though white also has some
good ideas here white often times place
set up with what I'm doing here Bishop
b3 Knight d2 night e to c3 later f4
however this is the only thing that it's
kind of puzzling here from black so if
you look at this a little bit you should
be okay in a position that is a bit more
unbalanced maybe this is an interesting
way for you to play um it depends also a
little bit on what kind of stuff you
play if white plays mainline yeah if you
play something really dynamic like the
Kings in you know so then you can also
think of course about moves like c5 or
94 and c5
I recommend c5 in my bank or gambit
repertoire and there see no problem with
the move either it's just the most it's
very sharp reply you need to study it a
little bit more if you want something a
little bit unbalanced and still not a
huge workload
maybe e6 is something you particularly
if you like the bishop here it's a good
choice um okay the next one
the next one is something that we had
already about the qga with you for and
here the ayah that's a good question I
mean not that others are not good it's
just like it's a it's a very common
question there are sometimes get it's
about this again in the QTA why isn't
white developing his black squared
bishop here um
the most common movie is III and
basically the question is what about
Bishop f4 what about Bishop g5 so let's
look at Bishop f4 yeah the problem with
this is this is delaying the recapture
of the c4 pawn and you're not entirely
sure that you get it back it's as simple
as that
the black plays for example the move a
six now it's not the only one but let's
say six how exactly do you get the pawn
back if white no place III I play b5 you
play a four and play Bishop e7 do you
get the pawn back it's not so clear one
problem is that this Bishop is actually
not doing anything and in some cases it
can be a problem if black plays a quick
Bishop to before and possibly not
possibly ninety five for example I know
that it's a bit cooperative but it's
very cooperative but let's say something
like this he's six and then yeah I mean
why everybody will cancel it right if
it's yeah even ninety five can be a
problem so you're not sure to get the
pawn back with III you are yeah you will
get it back I mean black can try stuff
like b5 but after a four he's not able
to keep the pawn ultimately because yeah
the whole play is just quicker yeah you
don't spend the time on Bishop the time
of Bishop f4 and one thing that I also
want to mention is that this move Bishop
f4
kind of Bishop g5 for their better it
kind of has this feel to it that you
feel that after you three your bishop
could be bad this is not happening this
is not a bad piece because you
automatically will improve the bishop
because black cannot play this without
playing c5 and to have some kind of
conflict in the center when the bishop
will automatically improve so this is
not a problem it's not that this piece
is stuck on the square for example if we
look at this if white if black does
something very slow let's say some
nonsense Bishop e7 this this this you
will always manage me form and the
bishop is in plain one they play better
they play c5 you castle they take the
bishop is in play on something like this
happens you play b3 Bishop b2 as
mentioned before this align your Bishop
becomes active on the diagonal so you
don't really need this move and e3 is
just making sure that you get the pawn
back now the next question I might be
getting to almost all of them me that's
cool
what would I recommend to an 1800 player
who likes offbeat aggressive lines to
play against the Scandinavian offbeat
and aggressive lines okay yeah it's not
so easy actually the Scandinavian is
something where you don't really need so
much offbeat because the best lines are
aggressive anyway without let's say
gambit in a pawn I would probably just
play a main line here like Knight c3
and now play one of the main lines in my
keep it simple Evo repertoire I advocate
to simply develop like this and if it's
a sharp play you often get 95 and G
falling against Bishop f5 this is
certainly an option just play main lines
because they are automatically
aggressive if you don't play
aggressively against the Scandinavian
Black is fine anyway so if you play name
stuff he would equalize and an
interesting line that you could think
about is this Knight f3 intending to
play d4 C form and not block the knight
and this will lead to sharp play because
you get to this kind of situation but
quite quite typically and here there are
some interesting lines I mean I did not
look at this perform
do we play deform
I think you have to play d4 here castles
no there was some before stuff this this
age three
there is some line here where I placed
before hmm
that here I don't know there are some
funky lines here because of them of the
opposite side castling it can get very
sharp and maybe this is something that
you could explore I would still
recommend playing in the main lines here
because they are aggressive and they
pose some yeah quite clear problems for
black not that black is in terrible
shape or so but just aggressive is like
normal against the Scandinavian it's not
like you get a boring position okay the
next question if I can use this video
series to answer question on my chest
over repertoires and sure you can ask
specific questions sure that's that's
possible yeah now the next question is
very general but no one he asked when a4
a5 or h4 h5 is useful in an opening I
sometimes say this looks logical and so
on but he does not see the logic and
this is a bit too general to answer
there are those flank pawn pushes in
some lines but it is a bit difficult to
answer that without having some concrete
examples so if you if you see the video
no arm know what Davis's name maybe you
can give me one or two cases where you
don't quite get why you would push air
or H pawn and I can answer that a bit
more specifically the the next question
is if I could do something about the
English Tech in the night off with
Bishop III this is what
it is all about
this is the ignition tech in the night
off and yeah honestly this is a bit way
again I mean it's a bit difficult to
make a full-scale video about this
because black has tons of setups and
even then it's it's it's you change them
it's a big range of stuff I'm happy to
answer more specific question I cannot
just make an overview about this opening
it would sit there for 20 hours even get
a vague idea in particular like this is
a total mainline it's easier to say
something about a sideline maybe you
have a bit bit more of a concrete
question there then I can try to answer
it I cannot just do an opening survey on
it um
okay there's a question here about if it
is a useful thing for learning an
opening to play the other side of the
opening against the engine so just to
check what positions you end up with
champ I'm not so convinced that this is
a good idea I usually recommend to
simply test out your opening against
humans in blitz blitz shares and rapid
chess and then make yeah statistical
analysis what worked what didn't work
what positions were fine well you've got
problems these kind of things it's much
more important to test it against decent
human opposition because it's a clearer
picture of what humans actually would
play the engines are often so far away
from normal chess that yeah and I don't
know if it is helpful I mean you should
use the engine may be to prepare the
opening and look at some stuff but I
wouldn't play against that it's just
too big of a mismatch okay the next
question is also about playing the
engine to prepare again I don't think
it's um it's a great idea
I am a reliable set up against the car
con yeah this is the second answer so
this is the Carroll and what has some
interesting options there what I
recommended in my book is two knights
and yes some other viewers of the video
put this in the text already they said
that I recommended that I'm still happy
with the recommendation it is not super
simple yeah it is in fact somewhat
poisonous line that quite often claims
victims because people have no clear
idea what to do against it and it's
still not something that you can learn
that in ten minutes so it's a bit more
more effort and if you want a clearer
option or a simpler option you can of
course play the exchange variation this
has been mentioned in in the comments
now and I have to agree that if you want
to make it even easier than the two
knights even though at the cost of not
having so much
I think trap potential then this is a
good choice one thing that I think is
interesting to keep in mind is that
after d4 d5 Bishop f4 the London this
has played a lot nowadays on our level
said we were talking about up to Magnus
and one of the main replies to this move
is c5 after which the the top guys all
play a three and now black has the
option to take on D form which they
actually don't do all that often but
they could do that and after he takes we
get the exchange color with Bishop to f4
this is not the most common move
actually yeah if we go to this again in
the Karim
exchange the main movers Bishop d3 if
you don't want to play c4 of course is
Bishop d3 but this is just a
transposition to position that many many
strong players are willing to play with
white and Atlas that says something and
strong black players don't actually take
on d4 in the London move water so that
means that probably there is some kind
of there is some potential maybe here so
this is something that I would recommend
if you want something extremely simple
that is even simple off then my
recommendation in the book the advantage
in terms of simplicity is the pawn
structure you define the pawn structure
super early on it is however unlikely
that you win quickly yeah in the two
knights or there was a Miss click I'm
sorry about that
in the two knights for example let's say
if I play a couple of blitz games
against typical opponent 17 1800 they
oftentimes simply play this and I have
worn so many games in this trap e9
you know it's quicker made threat was on
f7 I mean I've had this on the board
maybe in 20 minutes games already
against decent players and I've seen
even I am sore I am level players easily
go into this position which is basically
lost yeah it's basically lost um this is
also very strong by the way that wins
wins upon
actually what I have in the book yeah
there's a choice you can play the Bishop
c4 stuff which is great or this is what
I do in blitz because oftentimes the
game is just over 115 but objectively
stronger is even this what I have in the
book where black simply loses a part for
no compensation this is just one tricky
line there are some others with the two
knights that can help to win some quick
games you don't do that in the exchange
but the exchanges again is even simpler
to learn wow there was a little bit tour
de force but I actually looked at all of
the question that could be answered in
that format there was the question about
something interesting about something
interesting against Italian which I am
again then I don't really know something
myself that is really exciting I'm happy
to share this information if I came
across it but I currently also would
have the time to analyze for hours and
hours to find something funky in there
Diane yeah okay so this was a forty
seven minute video then so bit longer
than intended but I actually have a
reasonably clean plate after the first
video so if you have further questions
or want to be more precise about some of
the questions that you had in some cases
as I mentioned I need a bit more info to
talk about it then please some add a
comment and be more precise or just make
a clearer question out of it like what
to do specifically against this I cannot
do a huge overview of the main line
opening ok guys hope you enjoyed it till
next time bye bye